hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to sister location
custom night now we got Freddie and Co
here and I've kind of devised a little
bit of a strategy see funtime Freddie
you don't actually need to see where he
goes you only need to listen where he's
moving and then if he says he's got a
surprise do the opposite door if he
sends bonbon through the same door and
so that's pretty easy to solve you don't
need to waste any power with that the
only thing you actually need to check on
is funtime foxy just like foxy was in
the original game and I'm assuming since
there's a lot of door banging that's
probably not good a consume power like
it did in the first game but I can't be
guaranteed about that I got to find out
about that and then just yendo it says
quick flip of the monitor so mostly I
just need to get good at the hotkeys to
do all this stuff so that I can be even
faster than trying to flip around
because in the future I'm gonna need
these hotkeys he's on the right hi
no you're EJ [ __ ] [ __ ] alright well I
got caught with my dick out [ __ ] me then
alright so that didn't go as planned I
went in with a plan I came out with [ __ ]
in my pants I'll try that again that was
embarrassing
that was bad just plain old bad we're
not even gonna talk about that that was
bad see I wasn't listening I was busy
blabbing my mouth you're on the right
Hey hello No hello was that you on the
left oh oh that was it okay no that
wasn't it no huh I got your number now
you do huh no hello no don't do that
whoa whoa okay no I'm okay
Jesus that takes the oxygen down real
quick yeah what are you doing oh that's
not good
okay hey don't do that stop goddamn it
my oxygen flow is going bad it stopped
no I'm not huh banged your nose on it oh
[ __ ] man yandi yondu yondu drops your
oxygen like a bastard
let's not do white wine Wow
go get him boy god oh my god that was so
much spit like it 2z do I get to see
foxy running down the hall
ah dammit I'm I'm gonna vomit oooh find
out if I can see foxy running down that
hall
oh yes one boy home no oh why no you
shouldn't
jack on for luck uh-huh that's not one
of your things
oh well I do boy boy
Yeow Oh birthday boy how about you shut
up no no no not really
what point okay I wonder what happens if
bonnet goes all the way across the
stream always probably death so we're
doing pretty bad but we just crossed
four am we technically could make it
just remembering by the other stuff that
we've done in the past good that sounded
like hey
man he's really freaking out by now whoa
whoo okay I wonder if that's anything to
do with the actual like gamer that's
just bugging out like that I got a map I
got to imagine that he's falling apart
right now whoa whoa
get ready no not yet not yet not yet not
yet I gotta win this how about no oh
also know you think that you get the
point that you're not welcome in here I
let him in right at the [ __ ] end no I
heard the knock from foxy Oh No Oh
unless I misheard and he was on the
other side but I don't think that was
the case I think I was just too twitchy
okay but I almost had it is gonna be
easy I got this is it I got it everybody
look out I got it I'm an expert at this
don't worry I've got a lot of practice
and failure so maybe I'll try success
for once
they're our doing great on power doing
wonderfully actually
whoa boy [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh Jesus
can he was he running oh whoa that was
that was super weird that was like super
weird oh man I was weird
he's on the right but I didn't forget
about that he's on the right and he's
trying to I went up there are they are
they still trying to stuff me into an
animatronic suitor they doing that thing
where they're drugged [ __ ] you
they're doing that thing where they're
trying to scoop out minors let's do I
better lot times retreat grub naps doing
good we're doing good we're doing about
as well as last time few too many foxy
hits he's on the right
you're not gonna mix me up with all the
towns I know exactly where you we rose
up and I'm gonna find you till you do
I'm not near cities buttons yet having
buttons to do this stuff is super
convenient and it's probably an
essential skill to be able to do this
but yeah my muscles are not ready for
that my muscles in this game are built
for clicking and I am NOT out ever sent
down with all this man I got I got all
cuts go [ __ ] oh it's probably a good
strategy to just follow with the mouse
where he is and leave it there whoa
unless you need to do that because that
way you have a physical indication of
where he is without having to retain it
in men memory and to flip over to the
right if he's on the right flip over to
the left Eve is he on the left but below
Rose here that throw rents a full
[ __ ] plan no no I took that up
yeah but I am the best in the world and
I've got a great smile do I get to go
home and enjoy my exotic burgers oh boy
hello everybody Here I am again mr.
purple guy love and life living life not
on animatronic at all gone I murder some
children because I gotta spread the
disease what the hell I am
oh boy it's time to go down Street pick
up the dog read maybe eats me oh I love
to be a killer robot it's a bad thing
I guess I was skinned there I had some
more lyrics to put into that but alas I
guess yeah that's what we're doing here
well I just I forced our that so I've
got angry ballet Freddy Coe and I'm
gonna try funtime frenzy now the only
difference here is that foxy is much
more aggressive and there's also the
introduction of Lowell bit but it seems
that yendo is actually going to be more
forgiving than last time so it shouldn't
be too hard
is that a good look for me just going to
be able to give me the power needed to
survive I'll go for it yeah you know I
can do this I can do this okay I can do
this
there's still nothing that's been going
in the vent and also I've got hair in
the middle of my face to block out any
possibility of me seeing this [ __ ] [ __ ]
lol
you mean round three bear hmm
that's that's heart jeez
okay it seems a lot harder okay ah man I
do not like to say lol no no no no no
ohh and Fox is gonna come down unless
I'm gonna be able to see if foxy bashes
the door and actually take some power
from me
whoa oh oh whoa Ronnie okay oh man I
love having that button how about no I
don't know if that took any power it
kind of jumped down a second but it
might have been it might have been just
because oh [ __ ] goddamn Anna was not
watching us
oh [ __ ] you oh jesus getting pretty
stressful okay I was not watching oh boy
[ __ ] off Lola Roni yeah this is pretty
stressful it's actually hard to hard to
concentrate
focus on absolutely everything that I
need to focus on
but it's good thing the Endo's being a
little more forgiving than it was last
time but I'm doing very not good on
power no foxy seems to be doing pretty
good and we're kind of on target for
power we're just eating up a little more
than our life just a little bit more
than I would like we're actually doing
relatively okay if I can get third above
30 with four am left B in golden shape
golden shape that's not a pun about
golden Freddy oh I don't even know if
it's in this game but there is golden
Freddy mode oh boy 4 a.m. we're doing
okay we're actually doing really good
like actually we're doing really good
here this is there's actually
ludicrously good so foxy must not take
any power when he hits the door because
otherwise we would be in a much worse
situation although I'm keeping him
locked down which is pretty good but and
also the tracking method with the moving
the camera over here comes oh good
that's convenient it's the same door
that I ordinarily would yeah you
wouldn't want to do that
oh man that bugging out is definitely
part of the experience here
Lola running okay man hard to keep track
and this is just with a few noisy
interruptions I do not know if I'll be
able to handle this with Sony with so
many pieces of noise that's on the other
side man huh man a lot of things to
juggle and there's only three
animatronics or four I guess oh boy
five am 23 we're gonna win this I just
got to keep this up I got to keep this
up but this is good training for going
into the future man I love the fact that
there's new stuff here this is like
genuinely really interesting new stuff
that he's put in with a few extra pieces
to the lure and it kind of dives deeper
into the mystery of what this all is and
that that is really cool the fact that
that's all integrated into cool free DLC
and that's what I like about DLC it
should add to the experience of the game
it doesn't have to be free if it's
enough but the fact that this is free is
actually just really cool man enough
kissing Scott to ass almost done almost
there almost there
and figuring out the law I need like a
hot key hacker keypad over here on the
right-hand side
I need the mouse with like the whole
keyboard yay I have another song and I
dropping the hottest on
that's terrible that was probably worst
song I've done yet I'm gonna live with
that now okay help here we go again oh
boy another day it's so fun and free to
be in the Sun and walk on this sidewalk
looks like my skin is a little more pale
than it was before that guy doesn't
trust me
it's a little odd that much game is
rotting off what the [ __ ] am i doing all
my neighbors hate me but there we go oh
man that is moderately concerning
because yeah that guy definitely did
question that whole experience there so
that is actually all the time I have for
this particular episode of five nights
at Freddy's sister location custom night
we've got dolls attack girls night
weirdos top shelf bottom shelf cupcake
and golden Freddy left which means that
we got one two three four five six seven
it's gonna be a long haul but I'm ready
for it this is good because I need to
get accustomed to every single element
individually and know how they work on a
basic level before I can layer them all
but I'm starting to piece together a
general strategy it all probably will
revolve around fine-tuning the exact
moment when Laura comes close to the
door other than anything else in
addition to the people in the vent which
are likely to be the little dolls not
the many marinas I'm talking about the
bibbity bobbity electro babies they're
gonna be bad but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoy this let me know where you thought
down the comments below as always I will
see
you in the next video by
[Music]